hi everyone and welcome to biology  professor this channel has grown to over  50 000 subscribers and almost 5 million  views since i started it a few years ago  my goal is to get to 100 000 subscribers  so please subscribe hit the bell to  receive notifications and then tell me  in the comments that you're a subscriber  so that i can say thank you  and now a bit about me  i have a bachelor's degree in  biochemistry and i have a phd in  microbiology and immunology so yes i am  a doctor  i teach college-level classes that focus  on biology microbiology immunology  infectious disease biochemistry  metabolism and genetics  i started this channel to share lessons  on biology topics that i really love and  that i find interesting i hope that you  enjoy this channel and please remember  to subscribe do it right now  and that way you can follow my channel  and learn all of the cool stuff that i'm  posting so happy learning and thank you  for watching biology professor